hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen and I am
watching Creepshow today this is a movie
that I had never heard of before Doug
Walker told me to watch it after
watching through the TAM tober fest
videos he's like I think you would like
this I think you would enjoy this and
I'm interested in it I'm not sure how
much I'm gonna like it actually watching
a preview of it and just kind of hearing
about the cheese factor I think I'm
going to be entertained by it I don't
know if it's something that I'd be like
let's watch this again
but we'll see anyways guys let's just
get right into it
here's creeps Oh Panama's never seen
okay I was uh I was wrong it's I loved
this movie it was so cheesy like the
animated comics in between all of them
and it's it's cool and creepy but funny
and so odd I'd loved this movie it
starts off with this terrible father
like hitting his kid because he's
reading this horror comic and then
downstairs the dad is talking to the mom
like reflecting upon what a good job he
did he's like that's why God made
fathers that's why God made fathers ah
no I they just needed their semen so the
first one is called Father's Day bunch
of rich people crowded around a room
talking about this ant Bedelia who
killed her father after he killed her
lover good start so every father's day
on the day she did it she goes and
visits her father and she shows up and
she's a little disheveled she drinking
Jim Beam out of the bottle she goes to
the grave and the father comes out of
the grave and I don't know what the
significance is between this the seventh
year I don't know why he hasn't done it
before but he comes out this year and he
attacks her and kills her on the spot
he's like I want my cake she didn't get
him cake when he was alive still angry
about it
can't have your cake and eat it too I
don't there's something there moving up
so two of the characters back at the
house are cast and her boyfriend and her
boyfriend is dancing around the house
like a stoned weird 70s Owen Wilson he's
got the big lips in the big eyes and
he's just go it's weird
it's odd he goes to look for a Bedelia
these people having giant cemetery in
their backyard with like hundreds of
tombstone who are they are they the
Hitler's who are these people why do
they have this at their home though
boyfriend do falls into a grave and dies
and dead dad day 'then dead dad David
dead dad Nathan goes into the house
looking for his GD cake and he kills the
maid she probably would've made it one
is it's like if he asked dead dad Nathan
comes out with that rich lady's head on
a plate with the candle stuck in it he's
like my cake I got it also just a point
I want to point out our cakes a thing on
Father's Day that's like a birthday
thing
Father's Day is like a card or like a
tie like like a riding lawnmower like
why is it Weis cake the thing it was
just so specific and weird st. Patty's
Day let's go hunt for eggs it's not
really but even know what I mean it's
just a little it's a lot okay
I love the comic book effects in between
like shows you some comments and some
panels of comics and then it goes right
into the next one this one was weird
it's called the Lonesome death of Jordi
Vernell or something like the last one
was mostly supposed to be scarier I
think this one was like more like creepy
like Twilight Zone II opens up on Jordi
and he sees this meteor fall and he
flips out his pans go all over his face
well I'll be dipped in shit if that's
not a meteor well I'll be dipped in shit
if that is a phrase that people say cuz
it's not Jordi it's not then he touches
the meteor and it burns his hand shocked
and surprised you know it just flamed
through the atmosphere and landed on
earth but no yeah you know attacked then
this horrible moss-like stuff starts
growing on his fingers where he touched
it and he's like touching his mouth it's
growing on his tongue and like you see
this flash of it growing in his yard
approaching the house it grew in like an
hour
so it's inevitably going to kill you he
sees his flash of his father in the
mirror who apparently has been dead for
a while and the father's like don't take
a bath Jordy you dum-dum don't take a
bath then Jordy takes a bath and then
you see him wake up the next day and
he's full-on like Grinch /the Grouch
from Sesame Street who's the green
characters the trash one rumps a lot
whatsit hill he shoots himself much like
the Grouch and Sesame Street I don't
know what I'm doing up you just see a
shot of the plant growing into town and
there's like this radio announcer on the
radio he's like well it's a green one
this summer lots of rain and it's like
bum bum this next one is called
something to tide you over
do you see Harry who answered the door
to this creepy old dude you find out
that Harry's wife used to be married to
the creepy old dude and then left him
for Harry and so creepy old dude is
jealous shit sometimes I could get
jealous it happens to the best of us
creepy old dude brings Harry to the
beach and makes him bury himself up to
his neck and this is legitimately
terrified because times are a real thing
and it's gonna engulf him and his very
life and it's stressful that I'm
stressed and stressed Becky the the girl
who left over Richard Richard Tommy what
are those knees Harry okay
Harry is the young guy who is very
distant
Becky is his wife who left Richard for
Harry okay now that that's all situated
in my mind okay and Harry are buried at
different parts of the beach and Richard
has these cameras set up to watch them
be engulfed in the tide it's very creepy
and he's sitting there watching them
just come to their early demise so he
goes home he puts on a velvet tracksuit
he's living his very best life he
reminds me of Jeremy Jamm in Parks and
Rec very much it see also you have not
watched Parks and Recreation stop watch
it why are you watching this right now
go watch it it's so good oh shit there's
ocean zombies yes and the ocean zombies
who are Harry and Becky who died they
bury Richard
it up to his neck and it just fades out
into this weird cheesy 80s comedy gold
it's really good I like this one the
best okay so the next one is called the
crate and it's interesting and sad those
are the two words I would use to
describe it there's a janitor he finds
an old crate at a school and he tells
the dean of the school and it's from
this Arctic expedition from like the
1800s they open it up and it's like a
werewolf who needs dentistry work is
that what it is is that what is that
what's in the crate is that is that one
of this there's a couple other
characters I skimmed by there's another
teacher who has this wife named Billy
who is a lot she's a lot and he always
has these fantasies of killing her and
it's really funny I think that's my
favorite aspect of this little vignette
his poor Gaius struggling through life
and he just it's all that gets invites
awful fantasies of death so the werewolf
huni's dentist work or he's like an ape
who has vampire teeth I don't know guys
he's a monster kills the janitor he
kills the janitors assistant Charley and
the professor runs to this teacher's
house he's like things happened and I
need help the teachers like I have an
idea so he gives the professor sleeping
pills and makes him go to sleep so that
he can go clean up the mess at the
school and lure his wife there so the
werewolf vampire ape dentistry guy will
kill her
[Music]
so she comes to the school sidenote
she's drinking milk and whisky which is
disgusting disgusting and then basically
he lures her down there with the monster
Monster eats her dumps the middle lake
and that's it except at the very end
he's telling the professor this and the
professors like you killed your wife and
he's like yeah it's cool though the
professor is like
yeah yeah no it's cool thanks super
uncomfortable and then the closing shot
is the monster like coming out of the
box under the lake so he can breathe
underwater and so he's like part ape
werewolf vampire dentistry guy who's
also fish the monster from the 1800s
you know the classic tale then there's
the last one called they're creeping in
on you oh god it's beetles oh my god
it's beetles I don't I don't like
beetles I would rather eat a spider than
even see a beetle I don't like they're
crunchy I've not seen Beetlejuice just
makes me sad I know you say his name a
few times he shows up but I don't like
saying the word beetle so yeah so it
starts off and this old dude is trying
to get rid of some beetles that are in
his like super futuristic apartment
futuristic for the 80s then you find out
he's a germaphobe he's a rich germaphobe
so he could afford this really
customized place it just gets rid of
germs and then this woman calls mr.
Pratt and she's mad because her husband
killed himself and her husband worked
for him and he's like doesn't care at
all he's the worst
and then another guy calls in this night
mr. Pratt he is very popular for being
this like germaphobe recluse very
popular guy he's talking on the phone
and he ends up eating a bug because bugs
were in his like Raisin Bran its
disgusting yeah this really nice guy
comes and it's like hey I'll take care
of those bugs for you and then mr. Pratt
makes a really annoying and rude comment
about him being black and being like a
service worker and don't like that at
all I hope beetles eat you just like the
worst fate I could ever think of and I
hope that on you so you you're not nice
I mean it'll start coming out of vents
and out of the sink and it's just No Go
Go no no no no no no then there's like
this huge blackout in the city because
there's a storm and mr. Pratt calls the
police he's like Do You Know Who I am
when you get super mad that the police
won't help him even though there's a
citywide blackout and all the police
know is that he has some bugs in his
apart
so he closes himself into this secure
room it's his bedroom shuts the door and
he lifts up his blankets and there are
thousands of beetles and it's ah I'm
just skimming through this this vignette
because it's uh I don't
oh I'm like they start crawling into his
mouth and then the lights turn off and
they turn back on and there's no beetles
anywhere he's just lying there seemingly
dead and then beetles start coming out
of his skin and it's horrifying and so
cheesy but very bad I don't like it
No so then the very end happens and you
see the whole voodoo doll thing where
it's back to Billy and his mean dad
stabbing him in the throat it's awesome
that's cool good ending something that I
notice in every vignette there was the
ashtray from the first vignette that's
what and the dildo or whatever she
that's how she killed her father
and it was in every single vignette
which I thought was cool this was super
cheesy super fun I really enjoyed this
movie for what it was and now I'm super
interested in the second one I can't I'm
gonna watch it for sure I don't know if
it'll be for this but I'm definitely
watching it anyways guys check out my
own personal channel I posted a video
there yesterday and I will see you guys
next week for the start of the Christmas
month well yay Christmas movies bye
[Music]